mikolai feels like a city with its fate
hanging over it
russian forces are about 20 kilometers
to the east now
there is a sense of inevitability about
what's coming next
some neighborhoods are almost deserted
stray dogs and cats now wander through
the abandoned homes
fuel is running out most petrol stations
are now completely empty
the trains stopped running some time ago
the railway station is now a military
outpost
dimitro plattenchuk shows us what
remains of mykolive's city hall it was
hit by a cruise missile just as everyone
was arriving to work one morning was
anyone in it at the time
such a six pill that people died
36.
missile came through on the fourth floor
where the governor had his office but
barely an inch has escaped damage
dimitro's grandfather defended mikolai
from the germans in world war ii he and
his brother are now doing the same 78
years later this time though against the
russians when was the last time you had
a day off
24
of february
three months ago every day you've been
working defending your country yeah from
5 00 a.m to
10 p.m
you must be tired
work because
it's our job
now
there is no running water in nikolai
so twice a day trucks with bowsers
circle the city for people to stock up
it was here we met lude miller filling
up plastic bottles for washing and
cooking
i'm 83 years old and my sister is 81 and
very sick she tells me as we help carry
her bottles the roads are being shelled
and my sister can't walk downstairs
we've had to stay here we will stay we
are old and we can't go we love our
homeland we are ukrainians
ludmilla lives on the third floor it is
a struggle for her to get up the stairs
and to be frank she has little chance of
getting down to the bunker when the
missiles strike in the middle of the
night
she shares the tiny apartment just two
rooms with her younger sister i asked
her what she thinks of vladimir putin
he's sick in the head she says can't
someone just kill him can't they remove
the sick old man
the two sisters will stay here together
they know they very probably might die
here together but whatever happens they
won't leave mikolav they only have each
other
is that determination and loyalty in a
way
is what russia is up against
alice debunker sky news in mikolai of
eastern ukraine